oh you've been playing hella phones to
titanfall I have been for the past
couple of weeks and now it's at on the
Xbox 360 yes sir let's check it out
let's talk about it here if you played
much of this yet the 360 I will not I
will honestly say I have not I've been
on obviously Xbox wanting it but uh I
will say that in the in the in the few
moments that I had to try out some
titanfall on the Xbox 360 I'm surprised
I'm very surprised what by how similar
it is yeah and I really thought that it
wouldn't be you know straight up as good
and III think you guys can see it's like
they're not doing too bad
crystal water is use a nice little kick
attack you like that I love the kit they
kept the kick attacks it from I like to
call them kick attacks too because we're
at Chris you reviewed this for GameSpot
just yeah have you played any of this no
I haven't got a chance it's been a busy
morning well with co-hosting the Shawn
method life you moving on and prepping
some stuff for tomorrow but yes I mean
you know looking at it in an action
obviously it's running at a good clip
there's not seem to be any kind of
glaring framerate stuff although that
does that generally you know issue that
people pointed out on the Xbox one
version tended to crop up when there
were like a ton of Titans on screen like
yeah and this is still early in the
match so we'll have to see we're about I
mean it's the textures don't you know
like you can catch them when you want
when you're running by stuff like maybe
there's a little bit less detail but not
yeah really like the overall impression
it seems to be very solid definitely
doesn't look as good as the xbox like it
doesn't look next Xbox one version
didn't look incredible anyway like they
looked okay like the PC will look better
right guys like
yeah there's nothing that you know
there's nothing here that makes me think
oh wow this is super old looking though
the one thing I'll say is in the match
that I got a chance to play before we
came on I will say that it seemed like
everybody was just getting into it I'm
sure that's not necessarily the case but
a lot of the people I was coming up
against didn't seem to know exactly what
they were doing quite as good as people
playing now on the Xbox one
yeah so I you know I might go xbox 360
for a little bit just for stompers odd
method some people write what generation
are you
I'm gen 3 actually over a gen 3 almost
gen form 47 so I'm almost there the
region requirements that's one thing
that I don't think a lot of people know
is that if they get real specific you
got to use the railgun to kill 50 people
to get through gen 3 to Gen 4 oh wow
yeah so it gets it gets a little steep
and if you've got any questions from Mac
or Chris about cider fall on the xbox360
please put them in the chat they will be
relayed to us on the stage posthaste and
to preempt one read it like reject like
that gen rien listing stuff is basically
the titanfall equivalent of pristine
correct you know you reach level 50 and
then it delivers those conditions to you
and you can reenlist and it like start
to back from you know the beginning in
terms of all your unlocks and what have
you and your level but I guess you gain
experience at an accelerated rate yeah I
think the first person or the first
Xavier Jana is like 110 percent I think
but then 120 and then obviously at 30 I
think I have not rien listed yet because
I've gotten both Xbox one and PC like in
the mid 40s I'm like close on both but
I've been splitting my time for various
reasons Oh squish all right I know Eric
Tay and
Bonita or try to get me to play on the
PC with them but I didn't want to split
my my efforts did that couch just appear
it did yeah and so like the know that
stuff this like you know you see the
occasional texture mishap on the other
things I don't like I don't think the
textures are as good either
yeah does that I mean that stuff to me
is not certainly isn't what makes
titanfall titanfall it could have some
impact on your experience depending on
what kind of you know preferences you
have these of the
fidelity but so far it looks so far so
good
yeah so in saying that in saying that
this is almost like like for the Xbox
one except maybe doesn't look as sharp
certainly not as good as the PC what do
you think about the whole of them
delaying this thing for a couple of
weeks the rumors around the industry is
that this thing was done and dusted
really before Microsoft decided to hold
it back for a further two weeks on so
ex-members given that there's not like
any sort of glaring technical issues
that makes us think like oh god they
really had to like scramble to get this
thing seaworthy then what other
motivation would there be for them to
hold it back yeah so like you know
balloons you'd be able to buy it on the
Xbox one and the PC for a couple of
weeks yeah they try and help move those
sales and I believe actually tomorrow
look at that dude the textures were yeah
on the Titan textures now look at that
dude now there they are
Danny that'll be interesting to talk
about tomorrow actually because the NPD
numbers are gonna be released or game
sales and system sales for the past
quarter I believe so you know Justin hey
Walt our news guy and Eddie those
they're gonna be sort of taking a look
at those numbers and analyzing their
you know what does it mean for sales if
the Xbox one outsold the ps4 during that
period of whatever vice versa you know
yeah I have to admit I saw targets deal
where they've got that yeah we had that
news story where target's got titanfall
Xbox one and 12-month subscription to
Xbox Live for like 400 bucks yeah I have
to say I'm tempted to want to do it like
even though I have an Xbox way I could
always use another like in a rain
console sometimes we have to do
titanfall parties and we do need to make
sure boxes all right I got some
questions here from the one on the list
Food Rules on gamespot asks when is the
titanfall on Xbox 360 review coming edge
the xbox 360 review is gonna be probably
tomorrow afternoon you know I haven't
had a lot of time to play with this yet
but looking at it it's basically a
matter of you know does this assessing
how how this compares to the Xbox one
and PC versions which I've already
reviewed if it doesn't very very
differently then there's not a lot of
work to do for the review because it's
it's pretty much there the ante analysis
still stands yeah but certainly end
today tomorrow you can look on GameSpot
for videos for detailing like
differences on the forums and my
thoughts on that and then it'll be off
to PAX East on Thursday oh yeah and I
got another question here and saying
that artists there are significant
differences between titanfall in 360 and
titanfall on the Xbox one
Warren come in with the damn statue so
you get this thing Wow this is the
length awesome legendary edition what do
they call it this is the I've got too
much money I want to buy a second Xbox
one in there right right does it like
lights up and you can choose red or blue
like that might want to choose red I
want that way yo choose food I want that
way
yo choose green it's like a German
techno party shopping aside that Titan
and like yeah the the guy up here like
faces changing different yeah Lotus face
change he's gonna spectrum like buttons
here a little jump pack but is well
yeah look at that but this is insane I
mean look at that but like this get all
up in that but right in there we're
getting it one of these away its little
my packs right this looks cool but like
I want it a part of it I want to play
with it I want to be like a pack another
one I think is this actual one there's
another one that'll be given away yeah I
thought that the monster devs that's it
yeah no it's at your love yet oh is it
soon yeah give it away more stuff with
the lobby at PAX East I had no idea
break it
I gotta keep that for myself oh yeah
sorry it says I've you haven't had a
chance to play it yet so you don't know
if there's any difference between those
do you know if there's any difference
between the server's dedicated servers
on 361 no I'm not sure I don't think
that you know I think on paper there's
parity between the two generations and
that's what respawn has said the whole
time you know certainly there's gonna be
technical specifications that differ
because of the power of the consoles but
you know 12 players all the maps all the
modes etc etc an Xbox one players don't
play with 360 players giggling Tain's
asking on Twitch this is the future
they're just an antonym console you need
more future to get that working first
yeah we like the Dreamcast where I had
the quake 3 got hacked this is to say
what PC player is so much fun when you
can play with mouse and keyboard and you
have the broadband adapter for the
Dreamcast just kill people just run
through people is awesome say that was
the future that's why I want to come
back I can't imagine why people don't
want that console Julie Julie did you go
into a different map Here I am
this is such a different map the more
things we can look at the better sure
there Ryan what's your weapon of choice
I would have to say and I guess right
now it's the plantain Rogan in a Titan
because I still need like 25 to get my
reach in that's not your weapon of
choice or weapon you want to triple
flame you're just like I need a run I
need to like destroy all these fools
what do you rock it is definitely the
triple set when I'm gonna tighten
something like last night and standing
if you get way up on somebody with the
triple threat that's just not great some
sweet grenading there you do the aim
down sights on the triple threat I
suggest that's a trick that I learned
from I think Ryan Schubert yes if you
the triple threat normally spews them in
a horizontal spread for a few
aim-down-sights it switches at verdict
it does ooh
and it does do some business yeah did
you try and get is this the level with
the water it's one of them one of them
yes there is some water that check out
some water I want to see let me go here
yeah murder that guy first there's a
more water behind you is it here yes
more I go that way everyone is what I
don't care about your score I just want
to see what the water looks like a new
version yeah they put on a bunch of fog
in there yes I think there's like look
water actually like look at that moves a
little bit like a surface that this
surface is totally flat on this water it
looks like yeah I mean you're these maps
and this is thing about these site
called Maps be huge
there they go out really far like you
can go out and hang out by all these
drop ships like Crysis and I never go
out this far why would you ever no one
is here it's a wasteland is that a big
barrier of stones yeah this is like SEC
norm and demand the edge of existence a
car repair is asking are there actually
any benefits to prestiging and titanfall
or his only reason is the only really
there to mix it up its I would say you
all it you know straight out it's just
the the dumb XP modifier that gives you
more XP and then it gives you the little
tag that says yo you did that yeah
that's it yeah so it's like flare it's
hard it's like badges on your shirt it's
hard when people ask that question to
feel like you've wasted your life made
about 10 hours yeah all right go mortise
the floor I'm early
any more question all right in the knee
refer to send them on to me oh I got
murdered you got car a carabiner yeah
car pinned old what's the like going
back and playing with like a new set of
like going back to the original guns you
still use that mainly machine gun like
most of the time right I can never
change from it
it's a it's a really good guy it's
really effective my stuff like I don't
know I prefer to like I find like other
guns more fun I like I like the smart
pistol a lot like I really do even
though it's weird I think I like because
it's weird because different because it
forced me to play in kind of a different
way didn't they patch it so that it
takes slightly longer to get the
maillard lock yeah they did a little
little balance down jump it was
reloading right there yeah I can tell
they're you know what you mean with the
got some noobs here on this yeah right
oh yeah I am kind of excited online but
I mean that's you know getting hit by a
Titan you're not seeing the titanfall
glowing
you are hearing they like incoming Titan
and you listen and half the time it does
it like two seconds for each way yeah so
it's not something like they're just
standing in this giant glowing Tyler
singing like it this is gonna be cool
but maybe I'll get some regen out of
this I don't know you know it's dry and
I do you like to rodeo
I love rodeo I constantly review it I
try to you know hop oh are you finding
this playing any different all back to
the way you know it's funny cos like I
would say that uh no was my first
response but there is definitely the
it's like there's a little you know
chopping this to it obviously you start
when there's a bunch of Titans and
Asians it got a little little choppy but
aside from that I will say I am
pleasantly surprised but I would have
never guessed the precip would you it is
well beyond yeah now it seems good
you're right though I'm starting to see
like it seems like I think Shaun was
alluding to this this morning as well he
was playing when we came in when I came
in this morning that the frame rate
seems to be a little more wavy like it's
kind of it has its peaks in value or
them like let's consist in there guys so
the question is yes sir do you think you
would notice that stuff if you hadn't
spent a lot of hours playing titanfall
on Xbox one or I don't think so I think
you know past the initial response I had
of like oh it doesn't look as good yeah
my necks you know thought was but it
actually does look pretty good yeah like
no I'll be honest if I wouldn't have
seen the Xbox one or PC version I don't
think anybody would
the wiser you know it's one of those
things though once you go back you know
of course yeah you can't differentiate
it really but you know for a lot of
xbox360 hours you know they should not
be I don't think anybody it's so far
with what I've seen anyways I don't
think people should be a it's not like a
it's not a bummer I'm like a battlefield
4 situation where you're playing it on
the Xbox 360 they're like real
substantive reasons to plan an Xbox one
to get 64 player matches as opposed to
38 right you know I'm saying about PC
the big wreath DLC never comes out
because it's busted exactly that's a big
reason to sort of shift you're you're
you're playing or to incentivize me to
go elsewhere you know that's how I felt
with this being good you know yeah we'll
see but this is a so far all punchable
that is my favorite thing squish explode
into little giblets are you still
playing me yeah really
that was unfortunate this weekend
por favor really all right I'm just
interested goodnight I paid to that's
that was the thing a lot of people were
wearing this wondering cuz on the
figures no like think what kind of
longevity game would that have people
worried that would you be I guess 15
maps pretty good yeah I mean we've got
we also have a secondary a second review
coming for titanfall from Peter Brown
who he has not really played a
competitive for online shooter since
like Halo 3 so he's sort of thinking the
approach of someone who you know I did
the review but I play these games all
the time he doesn't play these games all
the time but you know this one appeal to
him so how is it from that perspective
he's working on that I'm not sure with
the ETA as maybe we can ask him when he
comes on but be interesting to see cuz
you know that that kind of longevity
you know Ryan's longevity with this like
John the dude was probably gonna be
playing a number of hours of a
first-person shooter this weekend anyway
yeah it happened to be titanfall cuz
it's 10 points gone right now it should
be used on their marketing alright Mac
we're gonna let us get back to directing
this show thank you very much for coming
on could you do that trick with the
camera thing let's go ahead a gameplay
go watch out thank you